- Welcome to re:Invent 2025.
Thank you for joining us for our session,
and this is the first
session that you have.
So thank you for coming in
and appreciate you giving us,
starting your day with us.
This is NET208 AWS
Networking Fundamentals,
Connect, Secure, and Scale.
My name is Rohit Aswani,
I'm a principal networking
solutions architect
within Worldwide Public Sector at AWS,
and I'm excited to be
joined by my colleague.
- Hey folks, my name's Dave DeRicco.
I'm a networking specialist
technical account manager,
which is a mouthful,
but I'm part of our enterprise
support team here at AWS.
- Thanks, Dave.
So the agenda for today's session is
we will start with global infrastructure,
then we'll dive into the fundamentals
of Amazon Virtual Private Cloud.
Once we understand those fundamentals,
we will go into the different
connectivity options.
We'll cover internet
connectivity, hybrid connectivity,
application networking, your
remote access connectivity.
Then we'll dive into the DNS piece of it,
followed by how you can
do traffic inspection
with various types of firewalls on AWS,
followed by how you can
monitor your network
along with the observability.
Before we begin, this
is a 200-level session
designed to give you basic building blocks
of the networking on AWS Cloud,
and we expect that you
have some familiarity
with fundamental constructs
such as CIDR notation, DNS,
IP routing, and so on so forth.
You can take some pictures along the way,
but we will be posting these
slides on the AWS event page,
so you'll have access to
that slides later on as well.
With that, let's start with a view
of the AWS Global Infrastructure.
AWS Global Infrastructure
includes 38 regions.
We have 43 local zones,
and we have over 146 Direct
Connect points of presence.
And all of this in Global Infrastructure
is connected with the AWS
backbone that we have built.
It is the most secure,
reliable backbone network
that we have built.
And you can scan this QR code
that will take you to the
page on the AWS Global Network
that you can take a look at it afterwards.
Now let's zoom in a bit more
into the construct of region.
So AWS has the construct of region,
which is a physical
location around the world
where we cluster these data centers.
And all of these data
centers are interconnected
with each other with
high-speed, high-bandwidth,
and throughput and low-latency links.
We encrypt traffic when it
leaves our secured facilities.
And a cluster of these data
centers is what we call it
as like an Availability Zone.
So here, you can see there
are three Availability Zones
that I'm showing.
And all of these Availability Zones
are also connected with
high-bandwidth, low-latency links,
and we also encrypt traffic
when it leaves these Availability Zones.
Now having talked about
region and Availability Zones,
you then create what we call it
as like Amazon Virtual Private Cloud,
which is a logically
isolated part of your network
that you get to define
similar to your data center.
Now within this region, you
have Availability Zones,
and Availability Zones have data centers,
and within these data center,
we have different racks,
and your EC2 instances lives
on one of these racks here.
Now with this understanding
of global infrastructure,
let's start to understand the IPv4
and IPv6 addressing options
that we have on AWS.
But before we do that, let's
define how AWS thinks about
public and private IP addressing on AWS.
The way we define this is
in terms of advertisement,
so AWS considers public IP addresses
as those advertised on the internet.
Whereas private IP addresses
are the ones that are not
and cannot be advertised
on the internet from AWS.
Now with this definition,
there are different options
that you can think about it.
On the left-hand side,
we have IPv4 and IPv6.
And at the top, you have public
and private IP addresses.
So let's start with public IPv4.
So you can get a public IPv4 address space
directly from Amazon, or
you can bring your own,
and you can follow the
Bring Your Own IP process
to advertise that from the AWS.
You can also get a contiguous
IP block as well from AWS.
That's also possible.
In case of private IPv4,
this is something that you
must be already familiar with.
This is RFC 1918 range,
which is 10/16, 172.31/16
so on and so forth.
We also have the carrier-grade NAT
that you can use for your
private IPv4 addresses.
And you can also choose to use
a public IPv4 address space
and you can assign it to the VPC,
however, we will treat that
as private in this case.
In case of public IPv6, these
are Global Unicast addresses
that you can use, and you can
get this either from Amazon
or you can bring your own.
And in case of private IPv6,
these are similar to your RFC 1918 range,
because these are not
advertised on the internet,
and you have the option of
using Unique Local Addresses.
You can also use a
public IPS space as well
for your VPC CIDR.
And you can also use
private IPv6 GUA space
for your VPC CIDR as well.
So far, we have talked
about IPv4 and IPv6,
and we will be showing IPv6
throughout the session.
So what I'm gonna do
is we are gonna define
how IPv6 on AWS is supported.
You have IPv6 configuration
that you can define in
two different modes,
you can have a dual-stack,
as well as IPv6-only.
Then we have AWS public service endpoints
that you use to access AWS services.
And the last one is the
private service endpoints
powered by AWS PrivateLink,
which we are gonna see in
the following slides as well.
So as of today, we support
150 plus AWS services
that support IPv6.
Now you may be asking,
where do I go find all these 150 services?
So here's a QR code that
takes you to a central page
where we list all the AWS
services that support IPv6.
Okay, now let's dive into the
fundamentals of Amazon VPC.
So now you want to build your first VPC.
We talked about region, and
region has Availability Zones.
Here, I'm showing two Availability Zones.
Your VPC is a regional construct,
and you define a CIDR range for a VPC.
Here, I'm choosing a 10/16,
and an IPv6 CIDR range for your VPC.
And when you do that, this makes your VPC
as your dual-stack VPC.
But now you might be thinking,
this is single VPC, single region,
what if I'm operating in multiple accounts
and multiple regions?
How do I do this at scale?
To do that, you can use
Amazon VPC IP Address Manager
that allows you to automate
IP address assignments,
you can plan and track
your IP addresses on AWS.
We'll start with an
example of private IPv4.
So we talked about the IP
addressing options on AWS,
which is public and
private for both v4 and v6.
So we'll take an example of private IPv4.
So when you integrate with
Amazon VPC IP Address Manager,
also known as VPC IPAM,
we define two scopes,
a private and a public scope.
A scope is nothing but like a container.
Within a private scope,
since it's a private IPv4,
you define this into the private scope.
You create a top-level pool.
Here, I'm showing a /12 as an example.
And then, I'm operating in
three regions for example.
And each region has a /14.
Now the way I'm dividing
this IP address base
is based on my organizational rules.
So for example, you have a
dev pool and a prod pool,
you can have many other pools
like the staging and test as well.
And here, I'm showing like a /16.
And if you're operating
across multiple accounts
and multiple regions,
you can integrate with AWS organizations,
and you can share these environment pools
such as dev and prod
with different accounts.
And then each application owner
can go ahead and request
a /24 as an example
to get that IP address base.
And you can do this across
all different regions as well.
Now what about IPv6?
So here's another example.
I'm showing an example of
Bring Your Own IPv6 with GUA,
which is an advertised space.
So as I mentioned, you
have different scopes,
you put that in the public scope
and you can have the rest of
the hierarchy as the same.
Now let's bring our dual-stack VPC
that we just built before, and
now apply these constructs.
So you get this IP address
range now from IPAM
and assign it to your VPC.
Within a VPC, then you
create different subnets.
Since we have IPv4 and IPv6 supported,
you can have an IPv4-only subnet,
you can have dual-stack subnet,
and you can also have an
IPv6-only subnet as well.
Now for IPv4, we support
creating a subnet size
of /28 to /16.
And in case of IPv6, we support
anything from /44 to /64
in increments of /4 basically.
Now once you define these subnets,
subnets are tied to a
specific Availability Zone,
as you can see, and you
can have many subnets
that can reside within the VPC.
Now each subnet has a route
table associated with it,
and when you have both IPv4
and IPv6 CIDR assigned to your VPC,
by default, we add a
local route within the VPC
that allows you to connect
with resources within the VPC.
And you can see here a route table.
There are other things that we will see
how you can enable
connectivity to internet,
and hybrid, and so on so forth.
And we will talk about examples
on how those route tables will look like.
Now once you define
that, you can then create
and launch your resources
such as Amazon EC2 instances,
your RDS load balancers,
and so on and so forth.
And when you do that, here,
I'm showing an example
with dual-stack and an IPv6-only subnet.
Each instance gets an
elastic network interface,
and it gets an IP address range
from the subnet that it is created in.
Once we create these instances,
now instances also have
some local services
that are available to them.
And for example,
we have Amazon EC2
Instance Metadata Service.
We also have Amazon Time Sync Service,
and a Route 53 Resolver service.
These are services that are available
to your instances locally,
and you can use, for example,
Amazon EC2 Instance Metadata
Service to get the user data,
and so on so forth.
Keep in mind here, we have
both IPv4 and IPv6 endpoints
that are supported for these services.
And for IPv6, you can do access this
using a Nitro-based instance types.
Now let's look at the Amazon VPC DNS.
So every VPC comes with a
purpose-built DNS resolver,
which we have at the
VPC CIDR plus two range.
And we also have the IPv6 address space
that I just talked about.
And we will see these
examples about VPC DNS
when Dave talks about in the
further part of the session.
Now let's talk about
the fundamental security
that you get on AWS.
We'll start with Network
Access Control List,
we also call it as like NACL.
Network Access Control List
are stateless in nature,
and you define this at the subnet level.
And when you define this
at the subnet level,
you can do both allow or deny rules,
and based on how you define your rules,
your traffic will be allowed or denied.
And the second option here
is to use security groups.
Security groups are stateful in nature,
which is basically like a firewall
that you can apply at the ENI,
Elastic Network Interface,
or at an EC2 instance level.
And you can control access,
it can only have allow rules.
And by default with security groups,
if the traffic is allowed,
if you have an egress
rule that allows traffic
to access a database
for example, by default,
the inbound traffic is
automatically allowed as well.
Now, we are talking
about IPv6-only subnets,
but we are living in a world
where we have both IPv4 and IPv6.
So how do we ensure backwards
compatibility in that case?
So here, I have an IPv6-only subnet,
and I have an instance within that.
If that instance makes a
query to an IPv4-only domain,
it goes to the Amazon VPC DNS
server that every VPC gets,
that performs a recursive
lookup to Route 53,
and it gets a response back
with an IPv4 address base.
Now you have an instance
that is IPv6-only,
but the IP address it's getting is IPv4,
how does the backward
translation happen here?
To do that, we support DNS64,
it is a setting that you can
enable on the IPv6-only subnet.
And what this does is that is,
when it makes a query to
the Route 53 DNS Resolver,
it gets a synthesized IPv6 address space
in the hexadecimal format.
So here, you see a hexadecimal format
of the same IPv4 address space
that I got from that instance.
Now DNS64 is just for
getting that address space
that the instance can then reach out to.
So we will see in the
further slides in terms of
how you can apply this
constructs when you want
to actually enable connectivity
to an IPv4 destination.
And with that, we will
transition into talking about
how you can establish
connectivity to internet
from your VPC.
So we will start with a public subnets.
A public subnet is something
that has a route table
pointing to an internet gateway.
So you create an internet gateway
and associate with your VPC.
You can then, this Internet
Gateway does the translation
of private IPv4 to the public
or the Elastic IP of that instance.
And you add a route
into the VPC route table
pointing to the IPv4 default route.
And once you do that, your IPv4 instances
can establish connectivity
to IPv4 destinations.
Similarly, in the dual-stack subnet,
you then add a default route for IPv6,
and then it can also connect
to IPv4 destinations.
But for IPv6, it can also go
via the same Internet Gateway.
So Internet Gateway supports
both IPv4 and IPv6 traffic.
Keep in mind that here the translation
that I'm talking about
here, the one-to-one NAT
that Internet Gateway
is doing, it's for IPv4.
Now we also talked about
public IPv6-only subnets.
So in this case, as I mentioned,
Internet Gateway can connect
to IPv6 destinations.
But in case of IPv4,
what you can do is you
create a NAT gateway,
which is a network address
translation service from AWS
that allows you to translate
traffic from private IPv4
to the internet destination.
And here, you can enable DNS64,
since it's an IPv6-only address space.
And what you do here is that
is you specify the 64:ff9b,
which is a well-known prefix
pointing to the NAT gateway.
When NAT gateway sees this traffic
coming from this well-known prefix,
it knows that it needs to
translate from 6to4 automatically.
And this is something that can be done
on your existing NAT gateways,
you do not have to create any net-new
NAT gateways to do that.
And keep in mind, here I talked
about a zonal NAT gateway,
but a couple of weeks ago,
we also launched a regional
NAT gateway as well
that you can use for these purposes.
What about private subnets now?
In case of private subnets, we
know that you have to create
a public NAT gateway that can then route
via internet gateway to go
to the IPv4 destinations.
Same thing works from another
dual-stack subnet on IPv4.
But for IPv6, you can use what we call it
as like an Egress-Only Internet
Gateway that allows you
to connect and initiate outbound
connectivity from your VPC
to the IPv6 destinations.
Similarly, for private IPv6-only subnets,
you define an egress on internet gateway
to talk to IPv6's destinations.
And again, you can use
the well-known prefix
via a NAT gateway to talk
to IPv4 destinations,
and that can give you
that backwards compatibility with 6to4.
Now so far we talked about
having internet access,
but you may have a requirement
where you want to block
that internet connectivity,
and you can block that
using what we call it
as Amazon VPC Block Public Access.
It comes in two different modes,
a bidirectional and an ingress-only mode.
In bidirectional, we block both
internet ingress and egress.
And in ingress-only, we
can block only ingress.
But you can apply this at
AWS account, Organizations,
or at an OU level.
But if you want to also create exclusions,
you can do that as well for
your egress inspection as well.
We talked about Amazon VPC so far,
and this Amazon VPC is
tied to an AWS account,
but you have different
subnets within that.
And what you can do is
you can share your subnets
that are part of the same
VPC with different accounts
using Resource Access Manager.
And those shared subnets can
then allow the participants
to create resources within that.
This is helpful if you want to conserve
your IPv4 address space, and
you have separation of duties
between the networking and
security teams to do that.
You can still control access
between different subnets
using security groups network
cases that we talked about,
or by putting a firewall in between them,
which Dave is going to
talk about later on.
Now we talked about
connectivity to the internet,
what about connectivity to AWS services?
So you can use Gateway
Endpoints to access AWS services
such as S3 and DynamoDB.
And what it does is that is
you create a gateway endpoint
and we support both dual-stack, IPv4-only,
and IPv6-only as well.
What it does is that is it
automatically adds a Prefix List
for that service within
your VPC route table,
and you can do that for
both IPv4 and IPv6 now.
And this allows connectivity
from your EC2 instances
to S3 and DynamoDB over AWS backbone.
It is private and secure.
You do not have to
create any other gateways
to establish that connectivity.
What about other AWS services?
We also have Interface VPC
Endpoint for AWS services.
And what you can do here
is that is you create
what we call it as like
an interface endpoint,
also known as like PrivateLink endpoint,
which creates an Elastic Network
Interface within the VPC,
and we support both IPv4
and IPv6, and dual-stack.
And the instances then send traffic
to these AWS services privately
and securely to AWS services,
and you can access these services.
And we support over
170 plus services here.
Let's talk about VPC to VPC connectivity.
The simplest way to connect
to VPCs in the region
is to use Amazon VPC Peering.
Here you can see,
you have two VPCs that
are non-overlapping.
We create and update the
VPC route table pointing
to the peering connection
ID of the other VPC,
and the instances can
communicate with each other.
Now, is this traffic encrypted?
To do that, we just introduced
a VPC Encryption Controls.
This is a new capability that you can use
to update and enforce
encryption in transit
for all of your traffic within the VPC
and across the VPC in a single region.
And what you can do that
is it comes in two modes,
a monitor and an enforce mode.
In monitor mode, you can monitor
your traffic within the VPC
and look at resources that
are not encrypting traffic.
And you can use VPC flow logs,
which Dave will talk about.
And in the enforce mode, you
can enforce which services
and resources encrypt traffic.
And you can also create exclusions
if you want to internet destinations
and some other destinations as well.
So how does this work?
With VPC Encrypt Controls,
you create and enforce
encryption on your VPCs
that then you can encrypt the traffic
between the two Nitro-supported instances
over the VPC peering connection.
You also have VPC peering that supports
across regions as well, and
everything works the same.
But what if you want to
have VPCs that want to scale
more than what VPC peering supports
and you want to have
transitive routing as well.
You can do that with Transit Gateway.
Transit Gateway is a layer three routing,
virtual router service,
that allows you to connect multiple VPCs,
and you can define your VPC route tables
and point to the Transit
Gateway as the next hop
for both v4 and v6 traffic.
You can have Transit
Gateways in one region
or in the same region, and
you can peer them together,
or they can be in different
regions, and you can peer them.
But in this case, we only
support static routing.
And in case of static routing,
which means that if you add
another region or a VPC,
then you have to add statically add routes
across all your network,
and that can become cumbersome.
To address that challenge,
you can use AWS Cloud WAN
and build that global WAN
connectivity to do that.
Here, I'm showing a
three-region deployment
where you can manage this network
using a JSON policy document,
and you can show your three regions.
And what it does is that is,
it creates a Transit
Gateway managed by AWS,
and we support dynamic
routing across this network.
Cloud WAN also has a concept of segments,
which is nothing but like a VRF
that you folks might be familiar with.
You can have these
segments either globally,
or you can have a
regional segments as well.
VPCs that are connected
to the same segment
enable connectivity, but you
can prevent that communication
by setting this flag,
then your VPCs can
attach to the Cloud WAN.
But the way you can do that
is by attaching the policy,
and you can define saying that
if there is a specific tag,
go ahead and associate to the
specific segment to do that.
How do you share routes?
You can do a segment route sharing.
And again, this is also controlled
through the policy as well.
Now let's talk about hybrid connectivity.
The first option is to
use AWS Direct Connect,
which is a private dedicated connection
from your corporate data center
to AWS bypassing the internet.
The way it supports is that is you connect
to one of our AWS Direct
Connect locations,
you can either have a
dedicated connection,
or a hosted connection.
It comes in different speeds.
And at this location,
you have an AWS router,
and you may either have your own router,
or you can work with a partner
that has their own router,
and create a cross-connect between them,
and extend connectivity
to your corporate network
through that partner network.
That's your physical connection.
Now what about the logical connection?
You create a logical connectivity
using virtual interfaces.
You can create a public VIF
to access public services.
And when you do that, we set up a BGP,
which supports both v4 and v6,
and we advertise all AWS prefixes
back to your on-premises.
You can also connect to a
VPC using a construct called
as Direct Connect Gateway and
a Virtual Private Gateway.
The Direct Connect Gateway
is a global construct,
which is highly available,
highly redundant,
and it allows your connectivity
to multiple VPCs in
different regions as well.
And in this case, Direct Connect Gateway
has a construct called as allowed prefixes
where all the VPCs that are connected
through that Direct Connect Gateway
via Virtual Private Gateway,
we advertise those prefixes
back to your on-premises.
What about Transit Gateway?
You can create a Transit VIF
connecting to the Direct Connect Gateway,
which then connects to
the Transit Gateway.
And then on the Direct Connect Gateway,
you specify what we call it
as like allowed prefixes.
These are all the prefixes of
your VPCs that you advertise,
that you want to advertise back
to your on-premises network.
What about Cloud WAN?
Cloud WAN also supports
with the Transit VIF
and interconnect with Direct
Connect Gateway there.
Now let's talk about Site-to-Site VPN.
Site-to-Site VPN connection allows you
to create IPsec-encrypted tunnels
from your corporate data center to AWS.
On the AWS side, you can
terminate this VPN connection
on a Virtual Private Gateway.
And when you do that,
we create two tunnels.
Each tunnel is 1.25 gigs,
and only one tunnel is active
at any given point of time.
We do not support ECMP in this case,
and we support both static
and dynamic routing.
What if you want to connect
to multiple VPCs now?
You can terminate that VPN connection
on the Transit Gateway instead.
And with Transit Gateway,
you get additional benefits
such as you can have
an IPv6 also supported.
We just recently announced
larger bandwidth tunnels
where you can have now up to
5 gigabits of bandwidth on each tunnel,
and you can also do ECMP.
Same thing works for AWS Cloud WAN as well
where you can have
multiple VPN connections
that are supported and you
can do ECMP in this phase
and the other features
that I just talked about.
What if you now want to
integrate your SD-WAN appliances?
Here, you have VPCs connected
to either Transit Gateway or Cloud WAN,
and you have corporate data center.
You can deploy these SD-WAN
appliances within the VPC,
with the VPC attachment as the underlay.
And on top of it, you create a GRE tunnel,
and exchange BGP prefixes
from these SD-WAN appliances
with either Transit Gateway or Cloud WAN,
and you can further extend connectivity
to your corporate data center
with either Virtual Private
Gateway or internet.
What if you don't want to
have those tunnels to manage
and you want to get the full bandwidth?
You can do that on Cloud WAN
where you don't have to
manage those tunnels,
and you can get the tunnel
less connect with Cloud WAN.
All right, let's talk about
Elastic Load Balancing now.
The first option in Elastic Load Balancing
is Application Load Balancer.
This is a layer seven load
balancer that allows you
to load balance incoming traffic on HTTP
and HTTPS to your applications.
Here, on the Application Load Balancer,
you can see, we support
advanced request routing.
You can do cool things such
as like path-based routing,
host-based routing, query
string, and so on and so forth.
And we recently announced
a couple of months ago,
a header modification where
you can modify these headers
before it gets sent to the targets.
And the Application Load Balancer
can then load balance traffic
across these instances,
and you can use different types
of load balancing algorithms
that we support here.
The second option is to
use Network Load Balancer.
And with Network Load Balancer,
the beauty here is that is,
it supports static IP addressing,
which means that you can use
these static IP addresses
to either allowlist
your specific firewalls
or specific clients that
you want to do that.
And we support both TCP, UDP, and TLS,
and we recently announced
support for QUIC protocol
as well on Network Load Balancer.
Once the load balancer
receives that traffic,
it can load balance traffic
across your targets,
and we support both v4 and v6 targets.
And here, the target group
we recently announced,
where you can do weighted targets
with Network Load Balancer as well.
And with that, I will hand over to Dave.
- All right. Thanks, Rohit.
All right, now so far, we've been focusing
on layer three connectivity
between our VPCs,
but there's another way we can think about
connecting our application together,
and that's with Application Networking.
So Application Networking
is a little bit different
if you're not super familiar with it.
Essentially, we focus on connectivity
between resources and
applications instead of networks.
So to do that, we'll create
an endpoint in our client VPC,
and then that endpoint will
be configured with listeners
appropriate to our applications
that we've got over
on the provider side here.
Now those applications
are going to appear native
to that local VPC.
So for example, when my
client here does a DNS lookup,
they're going to get an IP
address for that endpoint
local to that VPC.
And there's two services we'll talk about
that can provide this
kind of connectivity,
AWS PrivateLink and Amazon VPC Lattice.
Now regardless of which
one of these we use,
this will allow us to use
identity-based access controls
alongside network controls,
things like Route Tables,
Network ACLs, stuff that Rohit
was talking about earlier.
And this brings us into a position
where we can start to talk
about Zero Trust as well.
Now I'm not gonna read
the whole definition
of Zero Trust there, but essentially,
it's this idea where we
use identity-based controls
alongside network controls to
improve our security posture.
Now I mentioned there's two services,
let's start with PrivateLink.
Now with PrivateLink, we
can access AWS services,
Rohit mentioned that earlier,
but we can also access
custom-defined services
whether that's for our
own internal consumption,
or maybe we're sharing those
out with a third party.
So to do that, we'll need a
Network Load Balancer to start.
And then we'll define target groups
based off of the different
types you see here.
And these will can support
different listener types
from TCP or UDP, with a callout
that if you're gonna do UDP,
it does need to have an IPv6 target.
And then we'll use a
VPC interface endpoint
to access that service
from the client side.
And these clients can be
IPv4, they can be IPv6,
or they can be dual-stack as well.
And that allows us also
to not only communicate
across different types,
but also have those
endpoints be in different,
you know, v4, v6 as well.
Now from consideration here,
you'll notice that I have
deliberately highlighted
these overlapping IPv4 CIDR.
So if you're in a situation
where you have overlapping IPv4 CIDRs,
PrivateLink allows you
to still have that
connectivity between them.
Now these clients and services
can be in different regions,
and they can also be
in different accounts.
Now from a security perspective,
the first thing that you
should know about PrivateLink
is that this is unit
directional connectivity.
Providers cannot initiate
connections to client resources.
So as a consumer or as a client,
I can connect to those
resources through PrivateLink,
but the provider cannot initiate
a connection back to me,
they can only respond to
traffic that I've started.
Additionally, from the provider side,
I've got some additional controls.
First, I can define service permissions,
which basically are IAM policies saying
which principals can access my service,
and I can also then when someone tries
to connect to my service,
allow or block access
to that service when they
try to create that endpoint.
Now from a DNS perspective,
PrivateLink is gonna create
endpoint specific DNS host name
for each service that we have.
So it'll look something like
what you have on the screen.
And when our client goes to resolve that,
again, they'll get an IP
address local to that VPC
using that long custom DNS name.
Or if you don't want to use that.
Well, in that case, you could
also specify a custom DNS name
for your endpoint service.
So in this case, I'm gonna
use app1.example.com.
I need to validate that I
actually own app1.example.com
before I can, you know, use that.
But once I do that validation
process, I can then use that.
And when my clients go to
look up app1.example.com,
that'll now resolve to those
PrivateLink IP addresses within the VPC.
All of that requires having a
Network Load Balancer though.
And you might have some
resources like these
that don't require a
Network Load Balancer.
And if that's the case,
that's where you could use VPC resources.
Now this is slightly newer,
we launched these last year at re:Invent.
And these provide that same
kind of secure, private,
unidirectional connectivity
without needing a Network Load Balancer.
So instead, we'll have a construct
called a Resource Gateway.
And with this Resource
Gateway, we can then define
what are called resource configurations
for each type of resource
that we want to use.
And the supported types
are up there on the screen.
We support FQDNs, IP addresses,
and you can also specify resources by ARN,
and we support RDS on that today.
Once I do that, I'll
create a resource endpoint
in my client VPC,
and I will be able to access
those resources that way.
Now a couple callouts here,
because this differs a
little bit from PrivateLink.
First, these are regional constructs.
You're not gonna do these
across region today.
You can however share them across accounts
using Resource Access Manager
to create that resource configuration,
share it with other accounts.
And each resource, just
like with PrivateLink,
is gonna have its own unique endpoint
with a unique DNS name.
That's gonna look again
something like that on the screen here.
And just like with PrivateLink,
if you don't want to use that,
you can create a custom domain name
for these resources as well.
We just announced support
for that fairly recently.
So if I want to use
resource1.example.com here,
I can now use that from my client side,
and that'll resolve to my end point.
Now one other call out here.
So we've got a bunch of resources.
As I add additional resources
or want to access additional resources,
I'm gonna need to create
additional endpoints
for each one of these,
'cause this is functionally
point-to-point connectivity.
So that works at, you
know, maybe a small scale,
or if I've only got a few
resources I need to access.
But if I wanna manage this at scale,
or if I have a lot of resources
and services I want to connect to,
well, that's where VPC
Lattice is gonna come in.
Now with Lattice, not
only can we use those
same resource configurations
we just looked at,
but we can also create
constructs called services.
I'm gonna take a quick moment
and talk about services here.
So services, you can think of these
as layer seven constructs.
They're very similar
to what we talked about
when Rohit had covered
Application Load Balancer
a few minutes ago, they're
layer seven, HTTP, HTTPS, TLS.
So we'll configure these services
with listeners and target groups.
And then we'll take those
services and we'll associate them
with a construct called
the service network.
And that service network
makes those services
accessible from clients.
And I'll talk about how
that works in a moment.
And we can also apply auth policies.
And these auth policies,
or functionally IAM policy
documents, that we can apply
either broadly at the
service network level,
or at the individual
service level instead.
Now from a client perspective,
this is gonna look pretty
similar to what we saw before.
I've got two client VPCs here.
My first option is gonna be a
service network association.
I can only have one
service network association
with a given VPC, but if I've
only got one service network,
that's a good way to go.
And this works with route tables.
So just like with a gateway endpoint
where it adds those routes
into your route table automatically,
the service network
association works the same way.
Otherwise, you can do a
service network endpoint.
And this endpoint is
gonna again use an IPv4
or an IPv6 address right
out of your VPC there.
Either one of those will allow you
to connect to your service network,
and can apply those additional controls
like security groups and
network ACLs on top of that.
So between the auth policies
and these additional constructs,
you're again going back to
that idea of Zero Trust,
where you're layering
these additional ideas
on top of each other.
And both of these, like I said,
will give you access to
your service network.
And finally, using those same resource
configurations we looked at earlier,
we can now tie all of this together
into a single service network,
so we can access our
services and our resources,
and both will be accessible
via that service network endpoint
and that service network association.
So for a scale, this is
gonna be your better option.
Now I've started talking a
little bit about DNS as well.
And earlier, Rohit had explained
how the Route 53 Resolver
works within a VPC.
You've got that .2 address
and that v6 address.
Using the Route 53 Resolver
is gonna give us access
to some additional capabilities.
First one, being Resolver DNS Firewall.
Now with DNS Firewall, we can
create either block lists,
so domains that we
explicitly want to block,
or we can create allow lists,
where we take the
opposite approach and say,
we only want to allow DNS
resolution to these domains,
taking that walled
garden type of approach.
So we'll define those,
we'll define any actions
we want to take on that.
We can define if we only
want these rules to apply
to specific types like A
records, AAAA records, et cetera.
And we'll associate all
of these rules to our VPC,
and then we can optionally
use some additional controls
to prevent against
things like DNS tunneling
and domain generation algorithms.
We can then start to use Resolver
query logging separately,
or in conjunction with this as well.
And like the name implies,
well, this is just going
to log your DNS queries
that go to that Route
53 Resolver in the VPC.
So it'll include source,
destination, any responses,
but it'll also give you any
information about rule actions,
or any effects that were taken,
as a result of your firewall rule groups.
So you take that, apply to your VPC.
And this can be super useful
not only for just understanding
what DNS traffic you have,
but also if you're trying to troubleshoot
any kind of like firewall
rules that you may have created
that maybe you're having
some unintended consequences.
I'm gonna put those aside for a moment.
What if you want private DNS?
You know, like you might have
in your data center today?
For that, we have this idea
of a private hosted zone.
So I'll create a zone here.
In this case, for app1.example.com,
and I'll define records within that zone.
I will say take that zone and
I can associate it with a VPC.
Now, as the name private
hosted zone implies,
this is a private hosted zone.
If it is not associated with that VPC,
nothing in that zone will be resolvable.
So in this case, when
I've got my instance,
I'm gonna query foo.app1.example.com.
Because of that association,
I can successfully resolve that.
I can also associate
multiple private hosted zones
to a single VPC.
I can also take those
same private hosted zones
and associate them with multiple VPCs,
so that'll give me a
multi VPC view of my DNS.
Now what about our data center?
We don't want our poor data center
feel left out of all the DNS fun, right?
So for that, what we can do
is we're gonna take these
private hosted zones,
we'll associate them with our VPC,
and then we're gonna create
what's called an inbound
resolver endpoint.
And that endpoint will allow us to resolve
those private hosted zones
from our data center.
So to do that, we'll create a forwarder
in our on-premises DNS server.
And as long as we have
some kind of private connectivity path,
so like Direct Connect
or Site-to-Site VPN,
like we talked about earlier,
we'll then be able to resolve those,
and we can optionally
choose to encrypt that
with DNS over HTTPS as well.
So from a flow perspective,
we've got our DNS server,
it's got our forwarder,
that server receives a query
for foo.app1.example.com,
and then that will now go to
our inbound resolver endpoint,
so we can resolve this
private hosted zones.
Now what about the opposite direction?
Well, we had an inbound endpoint,
now we've got an outbound endpoint.
The same idea here before,
we had a forwarder in
our on-premises server.
Now we're gonna create
forwarding rules instead.
And these forwarding rules will point
to our on-premises data center,
in this case, for corp.example.com.
We'll take those forwarding rules.
We could also choose
to delegate if we want,
and we'll associate them with our VPC.
Once we do that, we can
again optionally choose
to encrypt those queries.
So from a flow perspective,
it'll look something like this.
We'll query, in this case,
for bar.corp.example.com.
We'll see that we have
that forwarding rule
associated with our VPC.
And then that'll send it to
the outbound resolver endpoint,
and then to our DNS server
on-premises for resolution.
There's a lot of associations here,
there's a lot of constructs here,
there's a lot of resources.
How do we manage all of this at scale,
especially if you're operating
in a large environment
where you've got a lot of VPCs?
So for that, you can take all of these,
and put them into what's
called a Route 53 profile.
We actually just added support
for resolver query logging
like you can see there.
Once you do that, instead
of having to manage
each of these separately, you
can take this one profile,
and associate it with many VPCs,
either within your same account,
or across multiple accounts
using Resource Access Manager,
giving you that, you know,
complete multi-account view of your DNS.
So we talked about DNS Firewall.
And earlier, Rohit was talking about
some of the basic security concepts.
But when we think about
our environment too,
we'll probably want to think about
adding a firewall in somewhere.
So there's a couple of different
places we might do that.
We might want to add a
firewall to inspect traffic
between VPCs, maybe between subnets,
maybe you know, on-premises in or out,
to or from our data center,
or out to the internet.
Now with the internet, let's
use that as an example.
It would probably look
something like this.
I've got a workload in a private subnet.
I've got a NAT gateway in a public subnet.
And ideally, I wanna place my firewall
right in the middle there,
in some kind of an inspection subnet.
Now there's two approaches we can take
depending upon what we want to use
to actually do that traffic inspection.
So to get things started,
if you're using third-party
firewall appliances,
you could use AWS Gateway Load Balancer.
So Rohit talked about two
types of load balancer earlier.
This is a third one, but
this is specifically designed
for third-party appliances to
provide native load balancing.
How it works?
We've got our load balancer,
we'll take our firewalls,
and we will create them
and define them as targets
for this gateway load balancer.
And then we'll use an endpoint
powered by PrivateLink,
a gateway load balancer endpoint,
and this will give us
bump-in-the-wire traffic inspection.
It's transparent to the source,
it's transparent to the target.
We're using route tables to
steer traffic to that endpoint,
to the gateway load balancer.
Load balancers will do what
load balancers do best.
They'll send it to the
targets, if that's allowed,
a traffic will return to
the gateway load balancer,
back to the endpoint, and then
route out to the internet.
Now the consideration here is that
even though we're using native
load balancing capabilities,
we still have to manage
these firewall appliances themselves.
If we don't want to do that,
instead, we could use
AWS Network Firewall.
And with Network Firewall,
this is a fully-managed
native firewall service
that gives us the same basic capabilities
where we can allow and block traffic,
we could do logging, things like that.
But it gives us all these
additional capabilities as well,
including some recently launched features,
like Managed Rules from AWS Partners,
and a Managed Proxy, which
is currently in preview.
Architecturally, this is going
to look exactly the same way.
Instead of a gateway
load balancer endpoint,
we have a firewall endpoint.
We'll route our traffic
to the firewall endpoint,
which we'll pass it to
our firewall service.
That traffic is allowed through,
it'll return to that endpoint,
and then go out to the internet.
Now the key takeaway here,
regardless of which one you use,
is that both gateway load
balancer and the appliances,
and Network Firewall will support
the same inspection architectures.
What do I mean by inspection
architectures here?
Well, here's an example using
that one we were looking at,
that's an example of a distributed model,
where we have an endpoint in the VPC
that's doing the actual
inspection right there.
And we could do that for
on-premises in or out
if we're connecting directly to a VPC.
And we could also use that
for traffic between subnets.
But we didn't really talk about
how to do traffic
inspection between VPCs yet.
So for that, we're gonna need
a different type of model,
and this is gonna be a
centralized inspection model.
And this is going to use
either AWS Transit Gateway
or AWS Cloud WAN.
And once we start to think about
centralizing our inspection,
well, we can centralize
our on-premises inspection,
as well as centralizing
our internet ingress
or our internet egress as well.
Let me show you what I mean.
So taking Transit Gateway as an example,
I've got some VPCs connected
to my Transit Gateway.
I can choose one of two
approaches with Transit Gateway.
Either can create a
dedicated inspection VPC
that has the firewall endpoint in it.
And if I do that, I do wanna
configure appliance mode
to make sure my traffic is symmetrical.
Or with Transit Gateway,
you have the ability
to create an AWS Network
Firewall native attachment,
and that will basically
remove the need for you
to create that inspection VPC.
I'm gonna use the Network
Firewall attachment for this,
but you could do the same thing here.
With the inspection VPC, functionally,
from the VPC's perspective,
you route traffic
to the Transit Gateway, the
Transit Gateway passes it
to the Network Firewall attachment,
the Network Firewall attachment returns it
to the Transit Gateway if it's, you know,
been inspected and allowed through,
and then routed back
to the destination VPC.
For on-premises, again,
assuming we've got some kind
of private connectivity here,
the flow is going to look very similar.
Instead of sending it back
to the destination VPC now,
we're gonna send it to our
on-premises data center.
From the VPC's perspective,
it still has that route
to the Transit Gateway,
and the Transit Gateway
handles that routing for us.
Now, internet egress is
a little bit different.
This is my personal opinion here.
You could go through the
Network Firewall attachment,
and then go through, you know,
a centralized egress VPC.
I think it's a little easier to do this.
So we'll take our inspection VPC,
and we'll add a NAT gateway,
and we'll add an internet gateway,
so we have a path out to the internet.
Once we do that, now our
VPCs can send traffic
to the Transit Gateway
like they did before,
but instead of having to go
through the Transit Gateway twice,
we inspect and we egress in the same VPC.
Now, that was with Transit Gateway.
Cloud WAN is pretty much the same thing.
So with Cloud WAN, earlier
we talked about how,
you know, you can have
different segments there,
we'll attach our VPCs and our
connectivity to our segments.
And then we'll create what's called
a network function group.
And this is a special kind of
segment specifically designed
to manage the routing for these
firewall appliances for us.
And we'll attach that inspection VPC
to the Cloud WAN network function group.
We don't have the native
attachment available today.
But from a flow perspective,
it's gonna look largely the same.
So again, we send our
traffic, in this case,
to our Cloud WAN core network.
That core network rides
it to the inspection VPC,
gets inspected by that endpoint,
returns back to the core network,
and then rides it to the destination VPC.
For on-premises, same thing,
we're gonna go through our core network,
the inspection endpoint takes
care of the inspection for us,
and then routes it back to
our on-premises data center.
Then finally, for internet
egress, same content applies.
We're gonna use that same inspection VPC
where we're inspecting and we're egressing
all in the same VPC.
So the takeaway here is whether
you are using AWS Cloud WAN
or Transit Gateway, whether
you use third-party appliances,
whether you use, you know,
AWS Network Firewall,
these concepts will apply the same,
giving you that flexibility that you want
for this kind of inspection.
Let's take a quick moment to detour about
and talk about remote access.
Earlier, we talked about this
idea of accessing networks
versus applications and resources.
And the same concept applies here
when we talk about remote access.
So for network access, you
could use AWS Client VPN.
This is a fully-managed
remote VPN solution.
It'll automatically scale up or down
based on how much you use it,
how many users are connecting.
And how this works,
you can define multiple
authentication options,
including certificate based off.
And then once you do that,
you can create authorization rules.
And these rules will allow you
access to specific networks
based off of the
authentication information
that the VPN receives.
You'll notice here, in this
case, I'm connecting, you know,
this engineering group can connect
to this particular CIDR block.
Once I do that, I can configure
other things like connection logging,
client route enforcement
to prevent route leaks.
And then from the target
side, couple things here.
First, my clients can be
v4, v6, or dual-stack.
And my targets can be
And in addition to accessing
resources in that one VPC,
I can also connect to resources
in that same VPC or outside of that VPC.
Again, as long as I've got some kind
of a routable path to those.
Now what if I don't
want access to networks,
but I want that different approach
where it's more that application
networking-based approach?
Well, for that, I could
use verified access.
And with verified access,
again, similar to what
we saw with VPC Lattice,
we're providing access to
applications and resources
without requiring a full VPN connection.
And we can add additional
group and app-level policies
on top of that as well.
This will support HTTP
and HTTPS applications,
and TCP resources.
Again, very similar to what
we saw with Lattice earlier.
Now for the first one,
HTTP/HTTPS applications,
we'll configure verified
access with trust providers.
And these trust providers
will include not only
identity information,
but we can also use device information.
So is my laptop up to date?
Do I have all of the
right security patches?
Things like that.
Do I have any software
that shouldn't be on there?
I can configure all of that.
And then based off of that information
from those trust providers,
I can now craft policies,
and I can do these policies per group,
or I can do them per
application or per endpoint,
configure access logging.
And because these are
layer seven constructs,
I can also choose to optionally
integrate AWS Web
Application Firewall as well.
From a target perspective,
I can connect to Elastic
Network Interfaces
you know, attached to an EC2
instance, or load balancers.
These do need to be
private load balancers.
And then once I do that,
I can define those per
app policies as well.
So remember, thinking back
to what we saw with Lattice,
the same concept apply here,
broad at the group level,
and more granular at the
individual application level.
And that will allow me to
provide that connectivity,
and those policies will then
be used by verified access
to provide that continuous
authentication in real time.
TCP resources are gonna be
pretty much the same thing.
Only in this case, instead
of using HTTP/HTTPS,
we're connecting to
services via TCP, SSH, RDP,
things like that.
My targets will be the same,
I can apply resource
policies on those as well,
but I've got now the ability to connect it
to additional resource types.
One is gonna be an RDS database,
which I could connect to
directly, or a network CIDR.
And a network CIDR is
gonna be super useful
if I have auto-scaling
resources that, you know,
are very ephemeral, they
scale up, they scale down.
I don't wanna have to manage
connectivity to all of those.
Verified access will make it,
so I don't have to manage that.
I can just connect into each one of those
as they appear and disappear,
it'll take care of that
for me automatically.
Ultimately, I can use the same construct
to access both of these,
whether it's HTTP,
HTTPS, or TCP resources.
Okay, now we've covered quite a bit here.
How do we have an understanding of this?
How do we reason about all of this,
you know, these network constructs?
Well, the first is, and
Rohit mentioned this earlier,
so I wanted to make
sure we came back to it.
First is flow logs.
Now flow logs, you can
apply them at a VPC,
at a subnet within a VPC,
or at a network interface,
as well as on a Transit Gateway.
And this will give you
flow-level visibility,
essentially metadata about your flows.
This is not a packet capture.
This is metadata about
those specific flows.
So include things like
source and destination,
port, protocol, bytes,
and then any actions taken
as a result of Network
ACLs and security groups.
And then all of that will get emitted
into our logging destinations,
Amazon CloudWatch Logs, S3,
or Data Firehose.
We've also sticking with Transit Gateway,
we can register our Transit
Gateways in Network Manager,
or if we're using AWS Cloud WAN,
we can use Network Manager to
get some additional metrics
and events from these two services.
And this will include things
like topology changes,
so as we add or remove attachments,
routing updates, as routes
are added or removed.
And for SD-WAN and VPN,
any status updates,
so if they go up or down.
All of those will get admitted
into the same logging
destinations as flow logs.
Network Manager also is
gonna give us visibility
into infrastructure performance,
and these are metrics
that we at AWS publish
that give you insight into network latency
and performance between regions,
between Availability
Zones within a region,
or within an Availability Zone.
So think back to that
graphic we saw earlier
where an Availability Zone
consists of multiple data centers.
This gives you that visibility.
Now these metrics will be
available in the console,
but there you can also publish them
to a CloudWatch subscription,
and then action off of those accordingly.
Now speaking of CloudWatch,
CloudWatch has a number of
tools that we can use here.
So for starters, let's say I've got
some public internet resources,
a CloudFront distribution, WorkSpaces,
a public-facing VPC.
I've got users who are accessing that.
I wanna understand what's
impacting their connectivity
to those resources.
For that, I could use Amazon
CloudWatch Internet Monitor,
and this is going to give
me internet performance
and availability metrics
by ISP and location.
So functionally, it'll give
me something like this,
a map of the internet weather
that would be affecting
connectivity to my applications.
Now that's for the internet.
What about hybrid connectivity
to my data center?
So for that, we can use
Network Synthetic Monitor.
And this will give us metrics
like a round trip time
and packet loss for
either Site-to-site VPN
or Direct Connect.
So in this example here,
I'm using Direct Connect.
I'll set up probes in these
VPCs, in this source subnet.
And as part of that configuration,
I'll specify the type
of probe that I want.
I can do TCP or ICMP, and I
can also specify, you know,
the port and packet size for TCP.
And then I can specify an IPv4
or an IPv6 destination on-premises.
And this will give me that
round trip time and packet loss.
And for Direct Connect,
this will also include a
network health indicator metric,
which is a probabilistic value,
and that will give you some insight
as to whether that network degradation
is within AWS or external to AWS.
Sticking with CloudWatch,
we've also got Network Flow Monitor,
and this is designed
for traffic within AWS.
And this will give you performance
and availability metrics
about specific network flows
by installing agents
either on EC2 instances,
or you can also apply this
onto your EKS clusters.
Once you do that, you'll
specify local remote resources,
and this could be any of
the resources you see here,
a region, a VPC, an Availability Zone,
a subnet within a VPC.
It could be a remote region.
And it could also be AWS services
like DynamoDB and Amazon S3.
And this will give you TCP metrics
and network health indicator
just like we had with
Direct Connect a moment ago,
as well as bytes transfer.
So you can see what that flow looks like.
Now what about troubleshooting?
We've got a lot of
components in here, right?
So if we even just take this example here
where we've got a load balancer,
targeting an Elastic Network
Interface, and a VPC.
Well, there's a lot of things
that could go wrong in the path, right?
There's route tables,
there's security groups,
there's those Network ACLs.
So if we wanna troubleshoot this,
this is where we could use a tool
called VPC Reachability Analyzer.
And this gives you hop-by-hop
visibility of the path
between a source and a
destination that you specify.
And crucially, it'll also tell you
if there's anything in the path
that is blocking connectivity
from that source to the destination.
In this case, it's a security group
on my Application Load Balancer
that's not allowing that traffic through.
So in addition to load balancers,
Reachability Analyzer
supports all of these
intermediary components
like Network Firewall,
Transit Gateways, peering connections.
And ultimately, this is gonna
be the best tool in your,
you know, sort of tool bag here
for fine grain troubleshooting
if you've got a specific
case you're trying to solve.
Stepping back a little bit more,
if you want to understand if
there are any unintended paths
to access your network, you can
use Network Access Analyzer.
And with that, you define what are called
Network Access Scopes.
Examples here, maybe you turned
on VPC Block Public Access.
You want to understand the impact of that,
or you want your instances
to only be reachable via a load balancer,
but not publicly facing any other way.
So you define this intent,
and the Network Access
Analyzer takes that intent
and uses automated reasoning
to determine whether
there are any unintended
or non-compliant paths
that don't line up with that access scope.
So this is gonna be best
for that broad evaluation
within an account or within a region.
Okay, we're just about at time here,
and we have covered a
lot in the last hour.
We could easily have spent a whole hour
on each one of these topics.
But fortunately, there are
a whole bunch of sessions
that are running this week.
If you're catching this
later or somewhere else,
you might be able to catch some
of these on YouTube as well.
Please take a moment,
grab a photo of this.
These sessions are ones that Rohit
and I picked out specifically,
they dive deeper into
additional networking topics
that we've started and
kind of cover here today.
And you can find all of the information
that you want to find out
about these, where they are,
times, et cetera, in the session catalog.
I'll leave this up for
just another moment,
give folks a chance to grab a photo.
And with that,
I wanna say thank you all
so much for joining us.
Thank you for starting your
re:Invent week with us.
I hope you have a
wonderful rest of the week.
And if you have any
questions, we'll be around.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)